Hi 各位
我今年前八個月過得有點太悠閒了
還跑去拉斯維加斯爽了一個多月
回來之後就認真工作一下
做我目前擅長的胎子騎當充
那最近一個半月是賺了兩百多萬
跟大家分享一下
然後
我是
主要都是操作美國的經濟數據公佈
我是一個非常理論派的人
所以就是
非常按照教科書的方式
去操作總體經濟學的數據公佈
然後主要是
目前地球的股市都是會
跟隨著美聯儲的
升息步調來漲點
那股市會對
下一次的
升息機率有一個預期
那每一次有新的
美國的重要的數據
經濟數據公佈的時候
下一次升息的機率都會有所調整
那市場也會根據這個預期的改變
相應的上漲或下跌
那這個是
我這段時間操作的主要的原理
然後
我是
就是
每天
都
逐天的貼當天的筍液
然後
過一段時間之後
我在
就是
貼
逐日的
日期加上
筍液
然後
就是
跟我前
十幾二十篇文
就是
可以知道
那這個是
絕對是真實的
就是
當天的筍液
跟我前面貼的
都是
有
負荷的
然後
好
稍微講一下
其實
從我的FB文
就可以看到
就是
最前面的是
NSCI的數據公佈
那這個我有拍
Youtube影片
大致上的原理
就是
我都是有講出來
那操作細節的話
就是
當然就是
會
大家做法會
就是
需要一些回測
那我是
比較沒有講到參數的部分
然後
也有的時候
經濟數據的公佈
不會
就是
符合經濟學的原理
那大部分的時候
當然是會符合的
像是
10月6號
應該是
PPI的公佈
然後
再來是
CPI的公佈
10月11
就是
PPI公佈的時候
是
它
剛好上漲
20點
達到
我的20點停損
之後跌下去
那這樣應該
也算是有符合經濟學原理
只是
但是
數據剛公佈的時候
就是
都還是會有一些隨機性的波動
剛好
也有可能會遇到運氣不好的情況
10月11的話
這個是
數據公佈之後
確實是大跌
但是後來又翻轉漲回來
變成停損
然後
後面的話就是
就是
FOMC會議
Fed Fund Rate
就是
升息的公佈
然後
會有
這個
美聯儲主席講話的記者會
然後後面再來是一些
非農就業數據的公佈
那
這段時間就是
美聯儲的
他
給大家釋出的訊息就是
下一次幾乎不會升息
所以
升息機率就從
快要
30%
20幾%
就下降到了
4點多%吧
所以股市就
大幅的上漲
這個就是
股市對於未來預期的改變
然後
這個
相關的
操作的話
我是會
錄成影片
就是
講給大家聽
然後之後我也會再錄
超強記憶
考試讀新術的
課程
這個應該會
給張旭數學來
來賣
然後
任何領域快速成為大師
還有心理學的系列的話
我也都會
放在這個YouTube
好
就是
前面太混了
所以
最後的這
這個
今年最後兩個月
希望可以多拍點YouTube影片
好
就是這樣
跟大家
分享一下
還有
預告我之後會拍影片